we've talked about the many reasons for
which Donald Trump's lawyers would be
right not to want Donald Trump to be
interviewed by special prosecutor Robert
Muller Trump believes himself to be
smarter than everyone in the room so he
might try to live thinking he can get
away with it not knowing what Robert
Muller's team already knows he might
show up and tell truths that expose
criminal behavior on his behalf or the
behalf of people working for him without
him even really knowing which would be
really bad if your Trump's lawyer Trump
might show up and say things that be
they true or false might open up new
lines of Investigation for Robert Muller
so there's a lot of reasons why if your
Trump's lawyer you wouldn't want Trump
speaking to Muller or his investigators
unfortunately for Trump and his lawyers
I told you yesterday that Moeller has
rejected the offer of an interview in
writing where Moeller will send Trump
questions and Trump's lawyers will write
completely sanitized the answers and
that was not good news for Donald Trump
there is more bad news for Trump with
regard to this possible interview which
is that they decided to do a mock Robert
Mulder interview and it was a disaster
right they did a sort of practice
session the way one might do before a
presidential debate and the idea was to
get Trump to start practicing the
questions that he might have to answer
if the interview does take place and
they had a whole list of questions they
had for hours during which they were
going to do this and they got through
two questions they got through only two
questions partially because Trump kept
getting interrupted by different things
partially because Trump just wouldn't
shut up and get to the answers
reportedly just going on endlessly about
only tangentially related topics can you
imagine having to train Trump to be
interviewed by skilled criminal
investigators mr. president can you
state your full name for the record I'm
Donald John Trump because actually John
wasn't my dad's middle name people think
it was but it wasn't and I'll tell you
John Trump was my uncle who would
brilliant guy a professor at MIT or
UPenn either way I mean both are great
schools you penned by the way I went to
UPenn graduated first in my class fake
news media won't tell you that Oh Trump
can't read Trump can't capitalize
correctly folks listen
the game is over but John Trump who I
was named after we got along great no
obstruction he did really serious things
with nukes and uranium and nuclear
weapons and that's what Iran wants Iran
wants nukes so I had to get rid of the
deal through the Iran deal right in the
trash it's done is that a yes on your
name is Donald John Trump sir I do not
envy Trump's lawyers for a second in
having to do this well we know that
Robert molars investigation is pretty
wide-ranging and the applicants have
been complaining about that of course
Muller asks about Donald Trump's big
beautiful businesses or his massive 2016
election victory Trump will be okay
then he'll he would love to answer those
questions no question about it there
actually is a silver lining here like if
I have to find some good news here the
fet for us not for Trump the fact that
they're doing mock interview suggests
that on some level they are thinking he
might have to sit down with Muller right
whether it's with or without a subpoena
but given how the mock interview went
his lawyers would be nutty to let Trump
walk in there voluntarily and if the
Trump Moeller interview was televised on
pay-per-view it would raise enough money
to end poverty right I mean this this is
this would be the most compelling
television I can imagine and this is why
I'm actually worried about the pulling
out of the Iran deal being a smokescreen
to start providing some pre-emptive
cover and we know that Trump will go
very very far in doing whatever he
perceives he has to do with Iran or
Syria or both
just to keep attention off of the
growing heat from Robert Muller and I
don't know what the timeline is on this
possible interview we heard from Rudy
Giuliani Trump's newest lawyer that he
hopes he needs time to get up to speed
and doesn't want to even talk about an
interview I think he said until after
the North Korea summit right so it could
be a while Giuliani is so trustworthy I
mean I'm sure we can take his word yeah
it's like do we even have any reason to
believe Giuliani has talked to anybody
about what the timeline is for the
interview maybe not but not good news
for Trump and I am I'm starting to look
forward to you know we had the Michael
Flint indictment that was a
much-anticipated event in this
tire saga we had James commis first
interview timed of course with the
release of his book which people were
very much anticipating I was sort of
anticipating those things
Trump sitting down with Moeller and we
don't even know when we would learn
about what takes place during that
interview that to me is really sort of
at the top of the pyramid of what I'm
waiting for yeah although unfortunately
it won't be televised I think the next
bombshell yeah might be Jared Kushner
indictment or Donald Trump jr.
indictment but that I don't have to see
I think Michael Cohen indictment happens
before that right yeah I mean think I
mean it Kushner and Trump jr.
it seems to me that Moeller has been
waiting on the family until later on and
maybe that's why Ivanka Trump hasn't
been pulled in yet either but we don't
know we don't know what's going on with
Muller needless to say four hours to
answer two questions not great although
maybe it's a strategy maybe if Trump
takes four hours to answer two questions
when he sits down with Muller Muller
just won't be able to really ask that
many questions and maybe that's what
Trump wants discuss this with us on our
subreddit david pakman.com slash re d di
t Chris Martenson joins me next today's
program is made possible in part by
futur vittor is a social forecasting
game where you compete with other
players to predict the future and it's
built on the principles of what's called
a prediction market a scientifically
proven way of using the wisdom of the
crowd to create more accurate
predictions about future events
prediction markets have been shown to
work much better than other forecasting
methods like polling or expert analysis
in many cases and futur has actually
taken the concept and turned it into a
fun easy to use social game you open up
the futur app and you'll see a whole
range of forecasts covering topics
across the board from politics to sports
and everything in between you can check
out my predictions and follow me to get
updates on my profile which is linked to
in the description if you're watching
this on youtube the tour is a great tool
to find out more about the world improve
your forecasting ability show off your
prediction skills to friends and even
better when you make predictions on
futur you're helping to create more
accurate forecasts for everybody there
mission of creating better predictions
is great and actually going in there and
seeing how well you can do at predicting
the future can be kind of addicting go
to futur dot-com sign up and start
making forecast it's free and it's
available on both Android and iOS as
well as on web browsers and that's f you
t you you are calm